i love your crew this is good this this
now makes so much sense people grossly
underestimate the impact of the three to
four people around them if you want [ __ ]
to change one of the quickest ways to do
it is to change the people you're
hanging out with now this is a rogue
statement these are boys from around the
way these are people you grew up with
i'm not talking about if you're good if
you're content i'm talking about if
you're miserable if you're super upset i
think it's a really smart practical
strategy to take a good audit of your
five or six people that are around you
because my big thing is complaining i
just believe in this [ __ ] i think
there's only two groups of people that
listen to people complain one the people
that have to your mom your dad your
brother and then group number two your
other loser friends
in the nfl they talk about guys getting
small groups that they're getting [ __ ]
by coaches and by front office and stuff
like that and it's a cancer in your
locker room 100 it could be a cancer in
people's life is what you're saying as
well 100 that's incredible